what's up everyone thanks for checking
out this week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest lean c-- news ever wish
you could get a little more oomph out of
your virtual machines google is happy to
now offer an expanded range of compute
and memory optimized machines these let
you optimize your virtual machines for
workloads that might need that extra
power you can get signed up for early
access now so get moving
this week we're excited to announce
Alaska file for GCP with elastic file
we've reinvented file storage as a fully
managed service this means you get to
take advantage of all the benefits of a
traditional file storage system such as
high availability and easy sharing
without the hassle of forecasting
managing and provisioning enterprise
storage all by yourself features like
petabyte capacity and auto scaling make
high performance compute jobs easier
than ever while built-in controls allow
you to optimize for price or performance
find out how you can improve your
workflow with alaska fly for GCP last
year we announced cloud memory store for
Redis our fully managed in-memory data
store service and because users
responded by adopting so quickly this
year were excited to announce cloud
memory store support for Redis version
4.0 available in beta as well as a new
manual failover API learn how to access
a new version and tour smart new
features like cached improvement and
active memory defragmentation you're
already running infrastructure is code
right no what if you need to quickly
replicate VMs between environments or
track changes or scale your
configuration by the thousands for
production the good news is that with
GCP you can use deployment manager or
the ever-popular terraform without any
additional setup you'll be able to make
changes to your environment in a way
that can be tested audited and
automatically applied according to your
change management processes allowing
your app to scale effortlessly with
massive increases in demand read
everything you need to know to get
started running infrastructure as code
today on the GCP blog the secrets out
we're making our Bey query migration
bundle offer generally available to
everyone that means in addition to
bigquery
you'll get proof of concept funding
support expert advice on architecture
design and online courses at no extra
cost
find out why an independent analysis
firm concluded that enterprise customers
could save up to 52% on total cost of
ownership over 3
by switching to the cloud if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link have
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you